it was intense rowdy rappin with intense
back yeah I looked in the aviary if you
look at 88 the top 10 rappers of all
have regular all are capable of killing
you you look at the top 10 rappers now
you might mistake them for boyband
[Music]
another dynamic episode of hot boxing
yes sir with my coworker Evan freshen up
everybody
hey we got a sensational guest tonight
we got the one the only with Khalifa
yeah I was cracking oh yeah look good
you look good smell good thanks bro
I'm put on some almond oil almond oil
hey yeah yeah you get your workout in
today I definitely did I tried yeah I
was seeing you getting buff I saw a
picture you with this guy from Atlanta
buffing you up yeah yeah yeah I've been
working out I've been in the gym now
probably like five days a week for for
two years yeah it feels amazing bro it
feels really good like push through that
wall like yeah still smoking feel smoke
fill mazing go a Friday I know I don't
have to really like worry about anybody
punch me in the face for real for real
so it's like you know it's just good
it's fun yeah yeah yep I'm having a
great time I'm having real good good
time learning not not only just the
martial arts part of it but uh just just
about like health and fitness and
awareness yeah you know if I can treat
my body better you know it's so ironic
you know in certain stages you know when
you're young you just want your body to
be strong because it's your ego so Brian
you want to be healthy because you you
want to live longer for sure be healthy
yeah yeah yeah I definitely reached that
point like 31 now so trying to try to be
around yeah we're the same age too
that's what's up yeah we're not saying I
know it although you taller hell what do
you do when you train
which would mean I smoked and while I do
kickboxing yeah I do kickboxing it's
like it's more martial arts though man
yeah my trainer he's he does Taekwondo
he knows he knows everything so he's
really well-rounded he knows you know
boxing he knows a lot of things so he
kind of uh kind of just sharpens me up
and whatever we're we're attacking let's
throw games do you do any weights or
anything I do a lot of ways so you do
weight from her yeah yeah yeah that guy
named I know that guy wasn't those ninja
training I was treating you you don't
[__] um [__] you got tell me what it's
like come on a glacier he trains
everybody Jay right yeah yeah training
everybody no yeah yeah that's exactly no
Ellis yeah no Jay Glazer school bro he
trains a lot of NFL dudes Callias gym
you smoke weed when you train yeah well
before and after it for and after I do
that too I mean people talking about it
for sure a lot of people say like mmm
they think that they could like outwork
me because I smoke weed I might get the
complete opposite bro my lung capacity
is applause it's like it's bigger like
you know inhaling like and like I'm
gonna take fat ass bong rips like you
can't do that you know I'm saying if you
can then you up there with the kid but
it's like oh yeah you know I mean you
can hit him with some science too cuz
cannabis smoke the THC and the CBD is
actually bronchial dilator so it opens
up your Airways I knew it like here but
I just didn't know the word for it yeah
what's the name again bronchial dilators
bronchial dilators there you go throw
that in a song yeah I was watching
whedon boy you got you got a lot of dope
[__] going on thank you
your documentary we could talk about
whatever you want I rode out there
beginning yeah yep cuz I was watching
your dock and I realized that say ya was
sort of your kick off yes sir I remember
when my brother turned me onto that all
that back in 2000 she was like oh seven
yeah oh seven yeah my brother was like
check this song out it was dope as [__]
mm-hmm but what I didn't realize was you
didn't really blow up until later yes
later definitely no what happened was um
the label kind of I didn't understand
the politics at that time and I was like
19 coming out of high school smoking
weed I'm like a real hip-hop kid I'm
like a real rapper and that was my goal
to prove myself in that area and I
didn't know about mainstream success and
that's what the label was trying to
prepare me for and I really didn't play
ball so I kind of just how do you
prepare for that yeah you don't know
yeah hell nah and it was kind of like
yes they move on to the next really fast
that's just how the industry is it
changes - yeah yeah it changes really
fast so that was one of those situations
where I just learned what I learned from
it and I was able to capitalize off of
what I learned from it cuz I I learned
two things social media was about to
take over and that they had no [__]
idea how to use it so that's how I you
know I'm saying capitalize off of it
yeah you know I thought that was really
interesting yeah yeah that you were like
oh there's this thing called Twitter
yeah yeah on your bully about it yeah
yeah uh-huh you're like you could say
whatever you want and you could get
everybody to see it absolutely and
Twitter account and Twitter containers
some people um during the eighties like
when I was coming out we didn't really
know who the hell we we're who we wanted
to be Twitter could tell you who you
want to be truth you could tap into a
lot of things to know exactly it's gonna
tell you what you would you know what it
was - that was really cool did you get a
lot of fan mail yeah tons of fan mail
that's what Twitter is yeah that go from
with different perspective cuz I used to
[__] my friend I used to get a mail they
send a great picture
oh dude call him right away bro right
away
Twitter's fan mail instant fan mail yeah
I being so much listen without I never
had this I was a young kid of 1920 and
they saying you know I got some swimsuit
models
bro can send me pictures of the messed
up and then I say where are you right
now where are you right now probably you
know tired of you know F and their fans
through pieces of paper move it
everybody know what you do before I
paper down on the way no I'm hitting my
fans right but now everybody knows
called a DM damn damn bro haha yeah
crazy bro well you've got your
documentary
I should be watching document to you
what's interesting about man it's cool
because like I've been in the game for
like 10 years but I'm still like really
fresh and really new and I think from
what I hear from the feedback there's a
lot of people tell me they learned about
me from the documentary it's like they
know me they might have freaking I know
you're [__] superstar in the hood of
[__] pitch I know everybody loves you
exactly that's amazing right
yeah cuz you don't see that a lot
especially I love ya and I love my city
- it's really uh it's really like a love
love relationship with pics bro I just
love to [__] out of my city and yeah you
get to see where I really came from like
the grind of course you know like I'm
successful but you get to see why like
okay [__] I don't want to be here no
more yeah come to that I want to be
better yeah oh yeah [__] the right yeah
you've also got your cannabis company
yeah really building got a child Jean -
Sebastian Sebastian yeah he's six years
old
yeah I mean I felt like I just reached a
point in my career where it's like you
know I could kind of tell how I got here
so far I still got a lot of [__] to do i
watch documentaries all the time and I
feel like it's really important to
inspire people come in
what's your favorite documentary um
anything that has to do with Bob Marley
Jimi Hendrix not the death or murder of
Tupac and Biggie anything about the the
the knowledge of weed I like anything
that's like spreading the message that
helps people with marijuana you know
we'll start there
yeah hey that's good stuff hell yeah
yeah we were talking music documentaries
all day I'm sorry because I'm a musician
like I just love watching a good story
of like you know how [__] wrote a song
or some [__] you know I mean yeah it's
inspiring
did you know Mike had his own record
label how are you back in the day well
year 1990 the nineties who's who's
trying to I know you had somebody that
always listen the guy from judge numbers
of Montana Def enjoy to see ya
so he went like this one day I came home
from prison right and so I'm in my Rolls
Royce and I got my Caravan behind me so
I'm driving from New York City to
Cleveland so during that process I gotta
go for our Chester buffer so I'm talking
divided so he said come over I'm in a
studio he got thinking all these guys if
they're famous now genuine one missing
him and all these guys right there
superstar Multi multi Manor but I did
everything it's a little skit bump they
lived in observe you sign them no oh
listen this is what happened no this is
what happened the font tasted mic these
are your artists I said what mm-hmm
you're not these are your artists so I'm
out of print I'm saying what you mean
these are my artists you don't know I'm
giving them to your artists I said no
I'm cool man I'm thinking it's a scam
with something like there's new money so
my mind is twisted no I don't want to be
involved with this I really need to me a
star look like what's a Madonna
dieter Roth yeah you know I didn't think
Mickey will make all these hundreds of
millions of dollars you don't look like
a super stuff my perspective huh gee I
thought Dinah Rossum I get Mariah Carey
that's what it's wrong looks like I
didn't know stars was looking different
they changed that make sense you know I
had no idea yeah
you know three like Tom Tim Berlin right
know he's overweight guy he could be a
sensation
yeah I had no idea it was like super
young but yeah still I remember her to
know that and then after that happened I
saw them blow up
that's whoa I want to do this and that's
why I bought a wreck on path irregular
did this [__] I said like 20 million
hours of my company right and there was
no nothing nothing no genuine no way how
long did you have it for I don't know
four years were you going to the studio
that would be lost in like you and
sometimes sometimes I would go to yeah
creative [__] you know living our
life bro everybody deserves that whizzes
hip hop and music always been your
passion yeah yep since you were cooked
yeah probably since I was like like
third grade I mean you were 17 when you
made that video or recorded say yeah
right I was probably like I think I was
19 19 yeah we were 19 yes that's your
thing yeah yeah yeah well I mean I was
kind of I was like I was always into
technology like ever since I was really
young I would just like take [__] apart
and put it back together and like we
didn't have cable in my house so I was
like [__] steel cable and my mom
would be wondering how I was watching
like pay-per-view and [__] yeah hell
yeah like naturally he liked when when
the internet came out and you could
steal music I was stealing music and I
was like downloading instrumentals and I
got really hooked on writing and
freestyling and battle rapping was
really popular back then so that's how I
kind of like got a name like battle
rapping and [__] so it was like
definitely something that I pursue like
through my team
and that I always knew like in the back
of my head like yo this is what I really
wanted to do like I played sports as a
kid like you know I mean anybody come
out of Pittsburgh that succeeded in the
rap business that you looked up to I'm
not at the time because everybody was
much like I know nobody ever came I mean
there was honestly the one person that I
could say who had done it like for my
generation cuz I was in my middle school
high school when he was doing his name
is Joe beasts and he has signed with dr.
Dre and he was out here working with
g-unit
and I make it mixtapes and [__] like
that when that [__] was really popular
so like being from the Berg and knowing
about Joe piece that was that was the
thing but there were a lot of cast a lot
of producers there's a lot of
underground you know I mean people
behind the scenes but nobody who you
could really put a like a name on and be
like your dad [__] from Pittsburgh and
they I always think it's interesting
being the age I am having seen the
evolution of Technology mm-hmm do you
feel like that it's awesome yeah I do
feel like like we were in it with
[__] tapes via tape see blu-rays all
the way minidisc the Internet the
[__] dial-up right now it's just like
a subscription it's not even like you
know me and music don't even exist no
more yeah it's not even [__] real it
is because you make it and it's a
vibration in this a sound and sound is
real but that's the only way what do you
think about that Mike I can remember
when hip-hop first started like an 80s
at 19 to 80 79 and everybody would have
they would bring out their turntables in
the park asunder and everybody that all
the street kids all the hustles all the
gangster girl anybody out anybody for
many any kind of mischief or anything
they all me on all in the same vicinity
looking god forbid if you look at
somebody because I'm connect either
somebody step on somebody's shoes and
it's a fighter gun battle right away it
was just intense
rowdy rapping with intense backs [__]
dangerous yeah I looked in the aviary if
you look at 88 top-ten rappers all have
records all all are capable of killing
you you look at the time
you look at the top you look at the top
ten rappers now you might mistake them
for boyband sometimes very dark back
then yeah very dark
they had a lot there was a lot it was
born in 87 be for their money and I guys
didn't understand the business if it's
new to them they didn't understand
getting money for this stuff they did
every day I mean it was raw as [__] back
then right crazy who park with a really
interesting I think a lot of people
really [__] scared for their lives at
that no light wasn't worth [__] back
guys crazy
night the big daytime the crack epidemic
came up friends are killing friend Robin
friends you know like there's two
different levels to like were the art
was that and where the business was that
late and there and the rappers were just
coming out of that they were looking at
we don't have to do that in the way
let's go in here and sometimes they get
pulled back down into that stuff yeah we
lost a lot of rappers and entertainers
back then and good people but it was
hard for castle I really separate from
that [__] - you know cuz nobody really
knew how far that they could take it so
they don't want to turn it back well
then what are you gonna do you you know
you're making figured I hit record then
you're coming back to brown for you
still gotta come back to your family
your family's plotting on you right
there so crazy - because it's like
people don't get set up for like
businesses or to like learn that you
need to establish credit and they don't
learn these things so like you're in
your early 20s so you might get a
million or a couple million and you just
think you ballin but then the government
really come back and [__] you over and
they take that [__] back and it's like
you back to square one and it's like you
got like say you pay your government
right boom now you got now you gotta
take care yourself your housing you live
and you [__] made a kid your baby's
mom the baby's mother mother mother yeah
yeah we did it in the family now once we
got some babies we're in the family now
so we pick and care everybody and they
want to live how you or they think you
live yeah yeah
it's real it got real it's real real
with you mm-hmm
but it's B
whilst after mm-hmm yeah because the
music makes it possible
yeah yep and that's why you smoke pot
whiz how much we do you smoke mad I
don't even really count no more I mean
what's your first J what time what time
is your first J wake up at 5:30 a.m.
yeah yeah early right through the same
time yeah yeah 30 everyone the morning
you one today a 5:30 we out with it and
that's that's usually when I'm smoking
it yeah
cuz I'm getting up I'm like planning my
meals for today planning my son's meals
for today probably listening to some
music from the night before that calls
for a joint do you wanna work with man I
want to work with dr. Dre that's a great
question yeah I want to work with dr.
Dre I want to work with jay-z yo great
man look out for shorty man yo man it's
time bro like look at this bro let's go
make a meme out of it
risen Dre yeah man
yeah that would be tight I want to work
with a Stevie Wonder Oh Madonna I want
to work with uh there was one more Oh
John Legend he's tired nice that's a
cool Crow you do a lot of crossover -
yeah I love that yeah mmm dig that yeah
yeah talk a little bit about that man I
feel like you've been that's a valuable
asset and how you've expanded your
absolutely and in your voice I will
consider myself like an alternative
rapper you know somebody who is
acceptable to do like good [__] but if
you do you hear me on some crossover
records it's completely fine it's like
duh that's ways you know what I'm saying
yeah and the world has accepted me as
that my fans love me for that of course
you got your people who talk [__] and
they want your original material and I
put you on but um you know you make that
stuff so you can get in the position
that you're at and right now I'm in a
position where people hear a lot of
different things for me so for me to
turn down opportunity
these will kind of be crazy I kind of
just expand try different things and if
it's dope we put it out it works and if
it's not then we hide that [__] nobody
ever hears it and I'm always down with
working with new artists as well no
matter what genre I don't wait until
people have 100 million followers for me
to work with them so if you know you
coming up and your artists and you'd be
like oh man it's my dream to have a
[__] whispers bro send it I'll knock
it out what do you think about the new
sensation in the DJ the DJ DJ like like
baby song like Eric yo I love that [__]
it's so yeah you say exactly yeah yeah
exactly it's a house sample but it's
like just that party environment and so
loose is so much fun
you get way more money doing those
festivals it's way less work you have to
say way less words in the song and the
songs they get more streams they last
longer
um the girls party harder it's cool man
it's awesome I love that [__] yes you
ever think about being a DJ yeah
absolutely I'm a DJ my neck October you
started where you really might do it I'm
open up DJ for more yeah what's up
senior team Gary sure just because it's
you doing it they'll be they'll be
they'll be excited to hear you playlist
and I'm pretty sure it's you're gonna
[__] kill it absolutely I'm very
confident to be in that into this mm-hmm
Mike you're gonna be you should do it
sensational you [__] Dylan I'm Pete
[__] just roll all your own joints no
don't take anybody's week bring your own
so let's bring the Tyson yeah Tyson the
Tyson brand bro absolutely bro have you
heard about the kind fest no kind music
festival was kind of Moosic but that's
Mike's music
that's why we're gonna do it this time
I'm trying to learn maybe Khalifa
building you've been to Khalifa building
that's the that's in Dubai yeah yeah I'm
not never went and shout out this video
right here I go nowhere because you
can't smoke weed there so I just hide in
my room and a bar nothing no you can't
make out with a drink tall and handsome
you know do you bedroom dude yeah but
like what if I'm in the mall and she
just wants to get busy like ready this
will be do you handle this with rocky
yeah pop star rocky bird who's my boys
let's go I like those kids oh my girl
really chosen
let's go let's go look ahead you can do
that somewhere Matt put it on the
schedule brother or Matt go to kid right
there yeah looking like a boss he go
boss
hey it's very full do coffee before the
show and then after the show we get paid
to fill me so nobody's gonna pay you
like we're gonna pay you either do let's
do this man how do you brought before
yes this is what's happening what's
going on living your life homeless
people who have basically were objective
is I love it they want to build a
homeless no okay yeah that's amazing
why not we can educate them give them
some tools
uh-huh some resources hmm help people
get back on their feet
Jim Grambling 3000-4000 ruins for sure
yeah I know little [__] small ass
animal town [__] sin nah hell no [__]
that [__]
so whiz you got Khalifa Kush yes sir
that's your cannabis brand you got a big
deal going on in Canada - yeah there's
wide open in Canada you over in Canada
yet well no not yet we're working over
win England we're in okay well Dubai is
gonna go legal soon now about the place
I was talking about [__] let's on the
load all in Harlan Oh am so damn
amsterdam school [__] we answer them
they only waited though we just said at
the same time just different ways
[__] wack oh my goodness I would
think the hash but is it is it that
their weed is not good or is it that
ours is just we've figured out how to
cause oh yeah California from my
experience they don't
hear about it the same like normal yeah
and they're happy there they're
satisfied with the level of where it's a
whereas we're banth in the progress you
know I mean so it's like yeah it is rich
it was spoiled yeah yeah yeah
what's broad like a [__] yeah
for sure
well what else you want to do with that
is that all products is that just a
strain yes the strain
I see weed going in a direction of less
smoking more ingest in oh you have food
product on weed incent stuff like that
so by owning the strange soap and on
exactly by owning the strain it's it's
an ingredient yeah as opposed to just
being you know in a in the store I could
be in everywhere you know I mean so I'm
I'm long long time thinking and you know
doing it the right way nice mmmm you got
your tour pail yeah yeah tell us about
that when did it start it starts in July
I don't know the exact date you got the
thing pulled up yeah yeah who you
Winston explosions are decent exposure
as me French Montana playboy party my
boy Chevy Woods and DJ drama yeah DJ
drama
well dramas from Philly but he living
land yeah yeah yeah you would think he
was from Atlanta pajamas my dad yeah
that artwork is crazy you know that shot
to my boy it's dope it's taste nap guy
yeah yep that's my boy Randy and his
whole team mmm like that
that's exciting we don't do alcohol here
do that chronic frog so people check
this out mm-hmm pre-sale begin pre-sale
for tickets have all have already begun
April 23rd rail tickets to unveil the 20
that's right 26 hell yeah oh there is
turn Elena uh-huh oh you guys are
starting in the shout out to ATL shout
out to the wings American deli last show
August 15th year in Boise Idaho
shout out to Boise I'll be so [__]
back people and Idaho me you yeah I just
probably like a little gang little
pocket no let me don't know yeah I know
do y'all like that I uh my favorite
spots is the Midwest really like
Cleveland already so hard
Cincinnati's gonna be crazy and
Indianapolis is gonna be crazy
Chicago is gonna be crazy Columbus is
gonna be Wow Cleveland is gonna be
insane
Troy is gonna be in yeah st. Louis is
gonna be insane I've never been to cam
cam cam cam oh can you guys say that
cabin not enough yet Missouri ham didn't
it's funny to me when I see you and
uncle snoop together because you guys
look like look-alike that it's my man
and you're kind of the young version
bringing the weed game you know what I
mean mm-hmm I love that new [__]
probably in like 2010 so maybe going on
just nine years going on ten years we've
been friends and it was just always cool
to me man like cool he could have been
like you know who the [__] is this
little dude coming out talking about
smoking all this weed yeah he did the
complete opposite he was like yo let's
make a damn movie breath and move to LA
let me show you how to do it and I was
what he did man he put yeah he put me up
on game and he's always been a constant
you know not only just an inspiration
but just like a big brother like a
person in my corner who I could reach
out to who reaches out to me and you
know that's cool yeah man is we went on
tour together freaking
we did it we did a movie like a promo
run together so we I don't you know when
you go on tour when you do anything on
the road you practically live with a
[__] right yeah
so to be able to do that [__] and not
get on each other's nerves and step on
each other's toes that says a lot too
cuz it ain't just like we likes to do
friends you know what I mean it's just
like weed buddies like know I seen this
[__] when he's hungry like you know
what I mean like I don't know if y'all
know what that means yes that way it'd
be like that you know you want a [__]
promo run and you got people ask you
questions you can't eat you know I'm
saying so we've been in like some
situations together where it was like
you get to see the real deal literally
and figured that smile
that's a bunch of Sun yeah he's six
his name is Sebastian he love rap music
he's into he's just he's in the
dinosaurs that's not to say he my son
went to that period what does he say
when she yo he loves it what I got
YouTube now so you can see over and over
yeah yeah but the thing see this was not
about the sales I say he's into girls
but the thing is he's so young he sees a
lot of women in my videos and he sees
like you know daddy daddy's a player
like you know I mean so he's like after
a while you start to realize what's
going on he's like hmm daddy wants you
to call some girls over you know I mean
I'm like five or six on my a why don't
we focus on some homework you know what
I mean but um he sees he knows
everything so I don't try to hide it I
just try to explain it to him what it is
of like you know daddy adds women to the
music videos because women make
everything better
you know once the kid lived that life
you can never have a normal sex life
again yo you never sleep with one person
again yo I mean all right Lee forests
are the prince
yeah like it mean is you're not gonna
wait it's whatever's gonna happen go
ahead no potato chips you're still young
still out there I'm sleeping with girls
right what is that sleeping with one
girl is really boring sleeping with one
girl is boring
I wanted to say that sleeping when one
girl is born nah not at my opinion only
having one woman forever to me doesn't
seem like what the [__] I want to be
doing right no I'm not right now yeah
not hell not now hell no absolutely not
no listen time will come when you die
for it what one woman yeah absolutely
when it happens I'm bracing that [__] oh
come on you know what you want no one
else you want no one else to be you know
what no one to look at [__] right
yeah yeah their time account I'm not
gonna try to fight it either I'm gonna
be right there waiting it's gonna win
yeah yep [__] right
I get you I'm planning on it yeah yeah
yeah it'll be the right one so it won't
be what I'm what I think is right so
that's good too because I'm still young
I'll know the [__] I want and have no
clue we don't know who we are what do
you think dude what how do we get here
how did we get here I feel like we're
all like I feel like we're pieces of
something that already existed so
whether it's like an alien a spirit a
tree that wanted to live and didn't get
to live its life out and get gets a
second chance to be a [__] human
being whatever the [__] the stars in the
dirt compiled together to make your you
into a gas that moves that's what we are
and flesh is just like you know we just
wear this it's like it's like what do
you think we going after we have a
little fun here I think you have a
choice I think you have a choice whether
you want to like stay around and like
you know just be like one of them lost
souls or you could just like live up
here and help people out yep I felt like
some a lot of people live on this level
but they have it but they're still here
physically you know what I'm saying
that's why I teach it takes you so long
sometimes to achieve that level
because then you don't even really care
not necessarily if you live or die but
it's like you know your purpose so
you're not you're not fearful you're not
walking around worried about you know
the things that threaten other people
you're not worried about money you're
not worried about you know getting hit
by a car or any of that [__] you're just
like you living up here and your whole
purpose is to help and to share and to
give and you know some people go for it
how do you know like who you are as this
artist who has this voice and this sense
of expression I'm still searching yeah
it's constant it's a constant journey in
my opinion but right now just studying
the greats and studying like my true
feelings what I really believe to be
true what do you want from the great you
know are you studying it for what you
want from studying well I know that
there's like a hunger in and something
that's embedded inside of all of us
right you're a champion you're a world
champion you're a fighter and and and
you mastered that but now I see you
mastering something way more calm and
way more chill and you know I'm saying
that's behind the scenes but it's as
powerful you feel what I'm saying it's
so so so to know that your journey
wasn't over and in life you know I'm
saying what some people might have
thought was the best thing that you was
ever going to do for you to recreate and
to note to make another path that's what
I study that's what makes you great not
not getting the belt but to be able to
do it over and over again at different
points in your life and still have that
same happiness and still feel successful
and still be able to help people and
look what you do why do you think people
do that do you think you know about told
you know anything about to toe secretly
but probably not and if you tell me I
might relate to something but ya know I
don't know what's the total totally
awesome I just put a shout on its own
the cool guy my bad my bad bro ain't it
told to him oh it actually is not all
happen that's how cool he is
so cool I took a toes
check this out with ancient contains an
ancient medicine that cures addiction
and depression and all these things
people do it and Mike had an experience
with it recently so happy for pitying oh
yeah thank you again thank you so with
everything again you know since then our
conversations have really gone deep into
questions of consciousness who we are
where we come from life after this you
know yeah yet what we're doing here ask
Mike any question about ancient history
or civilizations and he knows about
mm-hmm I know he's a big fan of
Alexander the Great
so many people in the world today can't
connect to the deepest thing within
themselves that is who they really are
right and you're you know you're so far
into this though that you you probably
aren't even aware of it at this point
because you're just being it numb
because lately aware of it you wake up
and have aspired to write some words
yeah absolutely 100% it takes work
that's channelings yeah yeah absolutely
it takes work like what Mike did yeah go
do do the toad I've seen the process
that's like that it takes deep
meditation and talking to yourself and
really figuring out the reason for what
you do especially in the position that
I'm in there's a lot of times where I
have to ask myself why am I doing this
it's not for money it's not for
acceptance it's to help people
hmm my fans love me for me and who I
truly am I'm blessed to be in that
position that I don't have to act like
anything that I'm not so I embraced that
and I know that deep down who you are
you know we all come from families and
we all have [__] up situations and
problems there's some people who know my
story and other things I've seen and
there's some people who never know that
wouldn't know that because I don't carry
it with me and you know the things that
you carry with you those are things that
kind of people let them define them as
soon as you let that [__] go that's who
that's when you yeah you really are your
true self and I try to stay you know
free of any baggage any [__] that I had
and even if it's just for that day you
know I try not to it's just the small
things and I you guys know so we could
talk about this [__] all day of uh you
know how the energy works and how it
moves and how things replace themselves
but um just on a larger scale I think if
people were just more conscious of each
step and how things play into each other
they would unlock it for themselves yeah
you know because it's just being aware
what do you think um God made us for I
think everybody has a different purpose
right definitely I have no idea me
either
yeah everybody has a different purpose
I'm I'm pretty sure that that that's my
opinion on that yeah yep yeah I think
you're right I think you're all put here
for a specific role know what that you
know mm-hmm I don't know no no that gets
decided because I think you're right to
i with another belief you have about
having a choice once you cross over into
the spirit realm you have a choice you
can stay in the spirit realm or maybe
you come back as something else isn't to
do more work mm whatever that might be
but it seems as though we're here to do
something yep you know I feel like since
I was a little kid I'm thinking a lot
only thing that we don't believe we do
every we did everything future only
thing that we don't do here love each
other yeah yeah and I think that's what
we're supposed to do the other day yeah
I was a [__] I don't remember where I
got this from cuz I'm stoned right
I might have been reading something but
uh it was talking about the balance of
like love and hate and how people shy
away from those being the same thing
like it's just one thing right but if
you love really hard then you say I love
this person or if you hate more than you
love then you say oh I hate this person
but it's the same things he's actually a
motion they're just extremes of each
other
like hot and cold are both temperatures
are just extremes for of each other so
learn more things with love right of
course you're gonna have situation where
you feel like you hate something right
but deep down inside do I really hate
this [__] or am I just mad or am I just
didn't get my way blah blah blah and
that's what I feel like you're saying is
if people could tap into more of just
doing everything with love even if
you're upset about it
you're allowed to be upset you're like
Avery you're allowed to be like oh [__]
this [__] but like I still love you like
you know I mean like I think that as
human beings is more it's easier to
grasp you know I mean and people if
people more people knew that we would
have more love I don't know I think us
as human beings we're fragile
emotionally mm-hmm you know we don't
have good emotional intelligence we get
offended very easy hmm and once we
offended it our minor allows us to
become more than what it truly is mm-hmm
you know and then I think you know
somebody's attacking somebody shooting
somebody killing somebody because
somebody feelings all right you don't
have to put your hands on nobody now
that you guys hurt their feelings
yeah kill you exactly yeah so what do
you doing stuff like that
well guys just get the feeling oh he
can't excuse me I said my films can you
please say sorry if you don't say sorry
doing the problem then I can understand
that and he don't say sorry I need do
sir I can understand if I ease can
understand okay it's getting managed to
come back off I write like doing martial
arts kind of taught me that control of
situations so it's like yeah I know you
talk emerges in a natural situation with
two people who have nose
control haha at all and that's the first
thing they're gonna do is like people
with no control yeah but that's why I
feel like martial arts can help people
you know what I mean or just learning
how to fight in general could stop a lot
of fear a lot of people wouldn't feel
like they need guns and [__] like that
because they're like y'all just beat
somebody's ass if I got a problem you
know when people learn how to fight they
don't that's fighting this daughter and
I know you'll whoop somebody's ass no
that's the first thing artist fighting
is not fighting you know yeah yeah I
mean of course you got [__] are
gonna be strapped and gonna have a knife
or something like that but at the end of
the day like to push a mine state of you
know when you walk out the house you
have confidence in yourself for like
that will help a lot of people out too
for sure no well I think empowering the
individual and starting on the
individual basis because really at the
end of the day that's what it is you
know right we all have to take
responsibility for ourselves
yep you know on our side of the street
yep hell yeah you ain't got your [__]
together can't can't worry about
somebody else I mean it's tough man
living in a community like most of them
are in community the actor wanted the
fate of all of us mm-hmm I mean they
always have to be um communication in
the community right cuz woman's think
but one person could deem us all trouble
yep yeah and you gotta have leaders too
absolutely people who lead by village
you take the village yeah like can't
just talk it like not anybody like in
particular but just like there has to be
people who put and [__] into action and
like the people who matter have to be
the ones we were putting it into action
because that's who people look up to
it's like you said like people know that
one person's name so they're not out
there busting their ass and really you
know putting it putting it down whatever
the times are you know i'm saying the
times are different now so it's like the
leaders whoever whoever
in the in the frontline gotta be you
know really about that action and that's
that's what's gonna help as well to I
think just as it has the people I don't
really see race you know I mean like I
feel like a lot of the conversations
before had had a lot to do a race but um
just as a people you know and I'm saying
like yeah if people just treated each
other better I you know I mean we would
just be awesome I don't care tote
enhanced in me I look at people
different I talk to people differently
yet have to go there yeah it's different
time and passion man hell yeah everybody
is doing the best they can now yeah with
what they have you know life is very
short and unpredictable that's a big
meditation for me if I'm ever freaking
out in a place with a lot of people
because most people are zombies you know
we got to be real about that too most
people have no idea who they are they're
eating tons of processed foods their
minds don't work but you know they can
barely function they're constantly in
their phones yeah people are [__]
asleep ya know so what I do is in my
head starting to breathe through my nose
I go hey up just like me everyone wants
to be happy
mmm and just like me no one wants to
suffer or feel pain mm-hmm and just like
me everyone is doing the best job they
possibly can
yep you know but it was like you know
what dude we're all equal dad yeah when
you put it in those terms
[__] you know life is hard let's just
work together
yep everybody [__] man teamwork well you
guys want to throw anything out there
before what do you want to see anybody
to know about you brother you want
anybody not again touch you - anything
[__] these [__] know how to
find me oh I'm out here [__]
it's the ground where everything was to
leave because we always Khalifa just go
on their type it was okay we're name
come from
wizdom and then khalifa for my granddad
Khalifa's arabic has to do with being a
leader and someone who spreads the words
like a like a yeah yeah yeah exactly
he's always from speaking the Quran yeah
yep so I just showed know where the the
Dom own wisdom you know my dad helped me
with that and then it became just Wiz
Khalifa and you know eyes leader is you
feel me trying to enlighten the world
man bring this message give give these
people positive role model man well
thank you brother yo thank you guys -
this was awesome yo I can't wait for
show always always great show Mike I
think so y'all come and see me - [__] ya
bro y'all don't come to the tour I'm not
coming to some pastors whatever I mean
you've already got the tomato your show
for Eileen I go on probably around like
11:00 we gotta cool no I probably go on
earlier - no I think we gotta get out of
here my two sons how old are they he
think I've 117 and 121 there you go it
smoke we clean Kipp he didn't smoke it's
cool how legal it is though right it's
beautiful
this is a gift from God
yeah for sure and the fact that we could
smoke and not get in trouble about
having kids neither say hey I smoke weed
and I have kids and then nobody's like
boom boom boom mmm-hmm I like that yeah
like that yeah
all right everybody well thanks for
watching thanks for listening check us
out be sure to subscribe to this podcast
on our YouTube channel hot boxing with
Mike Tyson check us out on iTunes and
Spotify
also you can find this dope-ass merch at
hotbox and pack merchandise what says
that this is an XL we got a sweatshirt
for you haiku and the great wave Khalifa
thank you brother thank you you guys are
great as well thanks blossom this
Ollivander yes
[Music]